voilà bien alors vous savez mont saint
michel que notre émission va un peu
partout dans le monde francophone et
variés comme vous avez l'art d'imiter un
petit peu de prendre tous les accents je
vous demande et de saluer car avec un
décalage cette émission va arriver à
noël après noël peut être après le 1er
janvier vous êtes donc souhaiter un bon
noël et un bon 1er janvier bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année on va commencer par les
belges puisqu'ils sont les plus proches
de nous ils nous reçoivent également sûr
j'aimerais si c'est possible m'adresser
à tous nos amis belges
ce serait si sympathique une fois et
surtout leur dire que comme ma grand
mère était belge parce qu'elle avait une
pizza cacher à bruxelles qui marchait
très bien oui et j'étais petite rue des
bouchers je vous embrasse tous sur
toutes vos bouches dessus je suis
maintenant lavezzi beau noël au suisse
oui mais alors là pour les suisses le
seul problème c'est que on a tellement
peu de temps dans l'émission pour leur
souhaiter un joyeux noël
parce qu'il parle quand même pas très
très vite
alors faudra faire une autre émission
pour rien on souhaite un bon noël est un
mauvais oeil aux allemands gharyan
c'est à nouveau une zone jaune grosses
cartes au bond et en étant malade
afrique du nord la tunisie nous sommes
reçues en tunisie en algérie au maroc
alors voilà c'est nouveau
on est très contents l'inde est aussi
éloigné les arbres de noël déguisait les
boules partout à tout autant à toi ça va
bien mais là si on redescend maintenant
on va vers l'afrique noire celle que
vous connaissez bien oui si vous savez
je voudrais vous souhaiter à tous un
grand joyeux noël même s'il n'y a pas
d'arbres de sapin mais des palmiers et
je voudrais vous dire que vous avez de
la chance de voir michel drucker en
couleur et noir et blanc
les personnes parties n'est pas
impossible qu'un jour par satellite sans
elysées à y encore beaucoup plus loin au
japon en chine au pays du soleil levant
alors pour eux c'est bien vrai
compagne d'accord mais ici mais écoutez
bien ce que j'ai racontée à tous nos
amis là parce que voilà ce qui se passe
par exemple quand vous lisez un texte un
texte à haute voix quand vous faites par
exemple une dictée à un enfant ou
quelque chose comme ça vous dit la
ponctuation vous dit pas la diva data au
point un animal un virgule etc
c'est normal mais quand vous dites un
texte à haute voix comme ça pour
quelqu'un pour n'importe qui vous n'avez
pas besoin de dire la ponctuation c'est
pas nécessaire ça sert à rien et
pourtant si vous sonorise y est la
ponctuation c'est à dire si vous aimez
tier-1 petits sons qui correspondrait
aux points à la virgule etc
vous verriez que le texte vous êtes en
train de lire ont une dimension tout à
fait extraordinaire vais vous dire
qu'est ce qu'ils racontaient les bouches
pas du tout par exemple le point nommé
j'avais pensé à sonoriser le point
pouvait le faire chez vous d'ailleurs le
point
c'est très facile ça fait comme ceci
écoutez moi bien ça fait donc le point
ça fait la virgule la virgule c'est
cocasse et féminin c'est esthétique une
virgule c'est très joli à regarder et
bien la virgule nous allons décider
ensemble ce soir que ça fait donc le
point ça paie et la virgule ça fait on
est d'accord pour voir si vous avez bien
compris les allées parmi vous dans la
salle je vais m'adresser à 2 3 personnes
pour voir nana mais oui on rigole on
rigole mais on rigole pas tellement
étonné je vais m'adresser à maxime
bossis maxime aussi ce dont je suis sûre
cher michel qu'en fin de carrière il
aura un nombre de sélections
pratiquement imbattable 1
j'ai bien l'impression et je vais lui
demander s'il a bien retenu la leçon de
me faire un p'tit coin un peu léger le
sait en gros c'est pas mal et pourriez
vous me dire qu'il voulait
comme jean alesi on va demander là bas
pour voir et écouter presse que vous
n'êtes pas non plus sorti de la berge
comme disait l'autre
alors monsieur je vois avec plaisir que
vous avez un physique il la rend vous
allez me faire le point s'il vous plaît
oui j'avais des prix panam sept moines
virgules c'est très bien et bien côté
c'est pas compliqué nous allons faire
une chose de l'importance d'en diviser
cette salle en deux parties à gauche
tous les points et à droite toute et
berio cet accord c'est très important ça
part de là à gauche tous les points à
droite tous les virgules
et chez vous dans votre salle à manger
ou dans votre salon vous divisez à
gauche les papilles à droite les mamies
et on y va et les enfants à tout le
monde paraît bien vous faites exactement
la même chose alors à gauche tous les
points sap est donc élevé donc alors
attention les points avec moi 1 2 3
puis simon pelé là
on a signé les propos hautement
intellectuel de ce que je viens de dire
attention 10,1 2 3 c'est bien c'est très
bien et qui régule bravo tension maxime
desbiens une équipe attention un deux
trois parce que tout va changer mais on
change pas place monsieur la belge est
gentil alors je compte y réserver savez
comment on fait le point la virgule nous
allons faire le poids bien compliqué il
suffit de mettre le point sur l'avenir
qu alors attention ça donne ceci écoutez
moi bien ça fait 2 3 voyez quand il
s'agit de monter les uns sur les autres
et tout ça tout ça dommage que
l'instrument je continue le poids de
suspension est pratiquement sûr ça fait
ceci c'est à metz 1 2 3
des grâces le point d'interrogation
alors grande interrogation il et
ventripotent il est rendu iard il est
sûr de lui
c'est très facile ça fait ceci écoutez
moi bien ça fait attention
1 2 3 vous avez bien deviné
et voici maintenant le point
d'exclamation alors qu'on est là mation
c'est très facile ça fait deux trois dix
seraient alors maintenant bon terminer
voici les deux points ouvrez les
guillemets la petite phrase point fermez
les guillemets c'est facile alors ça
mais aussi regarder ça fait deux points
ouvrez les guillemets la petite phrase
points fermez les guillemets à toute
vitesse a fait comme ça
abu dhabi
c'est pas grave on peut mettre en
application ce que nous venons de dire
parce qu'imaginez chez pas mal moins
matin mitterrand qui commencera faire un
discours
françaises français imaginent laon
michel vaudry voir la gentillesse de ma
portée oui s'il vous plaît un livre ou
une application
nous allons n'est ce pas mettre en
application ce que nous venons
d'apprendre à la dans un texte nous a
amené la vie de châteaubriant ouais la
vie de châteaubriant que m'a offert ma
petite maman il ya très longtemps à
point à point et que j'ai eu à poil et
châteaubriant un point oui c'est amusant
à la gambie alors là vous allez voir ça
prend toute sa dimension maintenant oui
absolument
alors michel vous allez faire la virgule
c'est parce que c'est frais c'est
parfait j'ai essayé le point
d'interrogation j'avais raté la can à
l'écouté bien alors écoutez bien alors
voici donc un texte de chateaubriand qui
relate l'histoire de lucien deux
battants près fou d'amour pour la belle
aurélie et le passage que je vais vous
lire c'est justement le passage où
lucien déclare sa flamme à la mairie sa
flamme à aurélie ne parle et voilà ce
que cela dit sur le lac du bois de
boulogne
lucien deux battants prêts prime
aurélie laisse glisser vers lui un
regard complice lucien s'arrête soudain
de ramé et s'écrit mon amour est ce là
la première fois que vous aimez origines
sociales c'est merveilleux je souhaite
que ce soit la dernière fois un grand
silence s'installe en un instant
lucien est auprès d'aurélie il la prend
dans ses bras il embrasse il la caresse
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
origine
plusieurs arrêts mais que cet amour
c'est ma vie c'est ma force et ma raison
d'être
non à ces mots auréline se lève et dans
la fureur dans la fureur normal
et dans la fureur de leurs élans le chan
ho et kabir le canoë chappille emportant
les amants enlacés dans l'aude néfastes
où
issia frugier ah mais oui je suis le
fils de bokassa faisant des malades et
tous les blancs qui sont ici ont essayé
de noirmont berlin dans une affaire
patriotes mais je vais vous dire je suis
en france présentement pour faire mes
études de président de la république je
travaille le soir au noir l'a toujours
l'autre jeu j'aime me promener dans la
rue avec mon père lorsqu'il sud est sous
nos yeux exorbités écart qu a paru une
blonde pulpeuse ladj de jeudi à mon père
alors on la bouffe tout de suite me dit
non et imbéciles on la ramène à la
maison et on bouffe ta mère attends
attends attends à tous notre jules dans
l'avion en acier qui nous a menés à
roissy charles de gaulle l'adjudant
l'avion j'avais une petite faim alors je
demande de la liste de passagers
elle adjoignent et le douanier gulumba
g6 web ouanna tient le passé par oui
j'avais passé pas les remarquer ceci là
non moi j'ai dit oui pour rigoler
atteint atteint signe particulier
voir photo 10 et une photo en noir et
blanc l'a dit oui j'avais pas la couleur
bon sexe bros attends attends il me dit
vous pourriez enlevez vos lunettes de
soleil quand vous me parlez là je ne
sommes pas mêlés
ce sont mes narines attends attends
attends j'ai rencontré mon ami honoré il
avait dans les bras énorme tournon la
suite il faut avec se tourne
présentement honorer sa mémoire le
médecin dit oui mais pourquoi avec le
tonneau présentement honoré il est
médecin m'a dit de revenir dans six mois
avec mes urines
atteint et la biologie attachée autour
du cou à la place du buggy habituel il
avait un énorme suppositoire d'ivoire je
suppositoire présentement aux lyonnais
ils disent les médecins
il m'a dit de suspendre le traitement la
course et nous les africains nous les
noirs quand nous aurons pris le pouvoir
nous ferons comme c'est marqué dans le
grand livre nous mettrons tous les
blancs dans la montagne aglagla les
blancs et les jaunes la plus cotée les
rues la plus haute et j'ai marqué dans
le grand livre
si tu veux réussir il faut battre les
jaunes et montez les blancs en neige